Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui on va parler des nombres premiers.
Les nombres premiers, c'est quelque chose qui fascine les mathématiciens.
Il y a une bonne raison pour ça,
c'est un concept extrêmement simple,
je crois que l'on apprend ça au collège
Et pourtant il pose des problèmes insolubles
aux meilleurs chercheurs en math du monde
et depuis des siècles.
Alors commençons par rappeler de quoi il s'agit.
Un nombre premier c'est tout simplement un nombre entier
qu'on peut pas diviser.
Par exemple 7 est un nombre premier,
13 est un nombre premier
21 ce n'est pas un nombre premier
on peut le diviser par 3.
100 non plus, on peut le diviser par 10.
Evidemment, un nombre entier on peut toujours le diviser
soit par 1, soit par lui-même.
Donc un nombre premier, plus précisément,
c'est un nombre qui n'a pas d'autres diviseurs que 1 et lui-même.
Alors vous pouvez, de tête, chercher les nombres premiers
2, 3, 5, 7
11, 13, 17, 19, ..etc
C'est simple non ?!
Et pourtant il existe des problèmes de maths insurmontables
rien qu'à base de nombres premiers.
Tenez par exemple :
Tout nombre pair est la somme de 2 nombres premiers.
C'est un mathématicien allemand du XVIIIe
Christian Goldbach qui a dit ça
Ça lui semblait vrai, mais il savait pas le démontrer.
Du coup, il en a parlé à Leonhard Euler
le plus grand mathématicien de son temps.
Peut-être même de tous les temps.
Euler qui lui a répondu dans un mélange d'allemand et de latin
"Dass aber ein jeder numerus" machin
Et ça veut dire qu'il est absolument certain que ce que a dit Godlbach est vrai
mais il sait pas non plus le démontrer.
Hé bien encore aujourd'hui personne n'a réussi
personne n'a réussi à démontrer que n'importe quel nombre paire
peut s'écrire comme la somme de 2 nombres premiers.
Et pourtant tout le monde y croit
chaque fois que l'on essaye ça marche
chaque fois que l'on prend un nombre pair on trouve toujours un moyen
de le décomposer comme somme de 2 nombres premiers.
Par exemple 8 c'est 5 + 3
12 = 5 +7
20 =17 + 3
Et généralement il y a même plusieurs solutions
20 c'est aussi 13 + 7
Aussi loin que l'on regarde ça marche
donc ça doit être vrai
et pourtant personne ne sait le montrer.
Quand on a quelque chose comme ça que l'on pense vrai mais que l'on ne sait pas démontrer
on appelle ça on "conjecture"
Et donc
Tout nombre pair est la somme de 2 nombres premiers
c'est la conjecture de Goldbach
Ce qui est fou, c'est que plutôt que de vérifier à la main
on peut utiliser un ordinateur
Et la conjecture de Goldbach elle a été vérifiée
jusqu'à 4 milliards de milliards
C'est-à-dire que tous les nombres paires
entre 4 et 4 milliards de milliards
on a trouvé un moyen de les écrire comme somme  de 2 nombres premiers.
Et voilà! On a un problème de maths hyper facile à comprendre
vérifié par ordinateur jusqu'à des nombres astronomiques
Et qui pourtant fait damner les mathématiciens du monde entier
depuis presque 3 siècles.
Les problèmes de ce genre là, il y en a pleins d'autres
ils concernent souvent la manière dont les nombres premiers sont répartis.
Tenez, entre 0 et 100
on trouve 25 nombres premiers
je les ai mis en rouge
Entre 0 et 1 000
il y en a 168
Entre 0 et 10 000 : 1229
Si on met ça en pourcentage
on voit qu'un quart des nombres compris entre 0 et 100 sont premiers
mais seulement 12% entre 0 et 10 000
c'est-à-dire que plus on va loin, moins il y a de nombres premiers.
ils se raréfient.
Alors on sait quand même qu'il y en a une infinité
ça Euclide l'avait déjà démontré il y a plus de 2 000 ans
je vous épargne la démonstration mais elle est pas très très compliqué
Voyons plutôt une chose que l'on ne sait pas démontrer
de temps en temps on trouve des nombres premiers avec un écart de 2
par exemple 5 et 7
ou alors 11 et 13
17 et 19
on appelle ça des nombres premiers jumeaux
il y en a pas beaucoup et ils sont aussi de plus en plus rares
Est-ce qu'il y en a une infinité ?
Tout le monde pense que "oui" personne ne sait le démontrer
On appelle ça la conjecture des nombres premiers jumeaux.
Et là aussi avec un ordinateur on arrive à aller très loin
entre 0 et 1 milliard de milliards
on a trouvé 800 mille milliards de nombres premiers jumeaux
mais est-ce qu'il y en a vraiment une infinité ?
Cette conjecture des nombres premiers jumeaux
on peut en faire des variantes.
Par exemple, on peut considérer des nombres premiers consécutifs avec un écart de 4
par exemple 7 et 11
ou alors 13 et 17
On appelle ça des nombres premiers cousins
Est-ce qu'il y a une infinité de nombres premiers cousins ?
On sait pas.
Si 2 nombres premiers consécutifs ont un écart de 6
par exemple 23 et 29
on appelle ça des nombres premiers sexys
Alors ça a pas rapport avec le sexe
ça a rapport avec le nombre 6
Oui, ils sont drôles ces mathématiciens
Hé bien là aussi on sait pas si il y en a une infinité.
Et on peut en faire pleins des conjectures comme ça
On peut regarder les nombres premiers consécutifs séparés de 14, 36 ou 1442
Et chaque fois la question est là même.
Est-ce qu'il y en a une infinité ?
Et on sait pas.
Et pourtant en 2013, il y a un progrès spectaculaire qui a été accompli
par un quasi inconnu Yitang Zhang
Zhang a montré que parmi toutes ces conjectures
avec des écarts de 2, 4, 6 ...etc
Il y en avait forcément au moins une de vraie avec un écart plus petit que 70 millions
Alors ça parait pas grand chose comme ça
mais ça a complètement débloqué l'étude de ce problème
En quelques mois d'autres mathématiciens s'y sont mis
et ils ont, collectivement, réussi à renforcer le résultat
en montrant qu'en dessous d'un écart de 246
il y en avait forcément 1 de correct.
Alors attention ces conjectures, au fond, tout le monde est convaincu qu'elles sont toutes vraies.
Mais pour l'instant le mieux que l'on est pu démontrer
c'est qu'il y en a au moins une de vraie en-dessous de 246
L'histoire de cette découverte, elle est assez sympa
quand il a publié sa démonstration
Zhang travaillait dans une petite université du New Hampshire aux États-Unis
Officiellement, il faisait même pas de recherche, il était juste enseignant.
Et puis à force de travail solitaire, il a réussi à trouver cette démonstration
Il l'a envoyé au meilleur journal mathématique du monde
il s'appelle Annals of Mathematics
Et en quelques semaines, il est devenu une super star.
Cette histoire, c'est un des rares cas où on ait effectivement à faire à un génie solitaire
un peu en marge du système traditionnel
D'ailleurs le système a pas mis très très long temps avant d'accepter ses travaux.
Donc si jamais parmi vous certains sont convaincus d'avoir réussi à démontrer la conjecture de GoldBach
Et je sais qu'il y en a.
Merci d'écrire directement à Annals of Mathematics
Pas la peine de m'envoyer la démonstration à moi.
Ça peut vous paraître dingue de passer son temps à essayer de démontrer quelque chose
que l'on a de toute façon vérifier par ordinateur
jusqu'à des milliards de milliards
Et donc tout le monde pense que c'est vrai.
Hé bien je voudrais terminer par quelque chose qui a aussi été vérifié par ordinateur jusqu'à des nombres astronomiques
Et pourtant, tout le monde pense que c'est faux.
Je vous ai dis que les nombres premiers il y en a de moins, qu'ils se raréfient.
Par exemple, entre 1 et 100, il y en a 25.
Mais entre 1 001 et 1 100, il y en a que 16.
Et entre 3 641 et 3 740, il y en a que 13.
À chaque fois on intervalle de longueur 100 mais il y en a de moins en moins.
Et en faite il y a plus de nombres premiers entre 1 et 100
que dans n'importe quel autre intervalle de longueur 100
Et ça marche pas qu'avec 100,
si vous essayez, vous trouverez toujours plus de nombres premiers entre 1 et N
que dans n'importe quel autre intervalle de longueur N
Chaque fois que l'on essaye, ça marche.
On ne sait pas le démontrer mais on n'a jamais trouvé de contre exemple
Et pourtant, on pense qu'il en existe 1,
quelque part.
Et pour des raisons que je vous épargne
mais dont je parle dans le billet qui accompagne la vidéo
on a un bon portrait robot du suspect.
Il faut savoir que si on prend N = 3 159
Hé bien, entre 1 et 3 159, on a 446 nombres premiers
Et on pense qu'il existe quelque part un intervalle de longueur 3 159
qui en comprendrait 447, c'est-à-dire 1 de plus
On l'a jamais trouvé ce contre exemple
mais on sait estimer qu'il doit se trouver quelque part
entre 10 puissance 174 et 10 puissance 1 198
Bon, il y a plus qu'à chercher. Au boulot !
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager
comme toujours vous pouvez retrouvez les actus de la chaîne sur Facebook, Twitter
Et vous pouvez nous soutenir sur Tipeee
Et pour ceux qui ne le saurait pas encore, je serais à l'espace des sciences à Rennes, le mercredi 5 octobre
donc on aura l'occasion de se voir là-bas, si vous y êtes.